[Music]
Jamie brought his daughter to the LA
premiere a baby driver which is all
about wild driving and that's something
that hits pretty close to home for David
do you remember that first time Korean
got behind the wheel 16 that in fish you
got an Infiniti an Infiniti man crazy
she crashes two weeks later fire hydrant
two weeks later and you know the
insurance is cold and interest is poppin
I think y'all keep maybe that's why he's
getting other daughter Annalise
comfortable behind the wheel at age
seven she's uh Emily's your driving
what would you drive down it would you
drive down the driveway was it your
chiid no g-wagen down the driveway I'm
looking at some of the country's finest
thugs
and of course young Mozart in a go-cart
over there you seen this kid move Jamie
and Jon Hamm played bank robbers in the
action-packed baby driver 23 year old
Ansel Elgort plays baby either getaway
driver with some insane moves
you do these incredible stunts I did as
many as they allow me to do I had a
parkour double I had a driving double I
had a ball double so I look at these
guys and say those are the real tough
guys those who I want to be like when
you were in the sense was there ever
like a holy beep moment where you were
like okay that was a little too close
you are actually on a working freeway
going the wrong way it's very strange
very strange feeling
do you ever push more and say like I
want to do more stunts
46 years old I got nothing left to prove
while Jon Hamm arrived solo at the
premiere last night I'm sure all the
women fans loved that I think they did
you